gestern bin ich im bad gestürzt der
kurzfristig wirbelsäule hin abgesprungen
ich lag für ein knappes stündchen auf
dem karl boden
ich zählte die weißen kacheln ich war
allein unheilbar krank vor zwölf jahren
hat sich ja parkinson in das leben von
richard wagner geschlichen
der schriftsteller hat der krankheit ein
buch abgerungen
aber man kann nicht viel aushalten was
er erlässt aushalten was real ist 1989
flow wagner von rumänien nach
deutschland mit seiner damaligen frau
der literaturnobelpreisträgerin herta
müller
weg vom geheimdienst securitate weg von
der überwachung 35 war damals ein
dissident
heute ist er 63 lebt in einem haus für
betreutes wohnen
unser neuer gegner heißt parkinson
der parkinson hat damals längst durch
die welt und alle sehen dass hinken
das sollte und hüpfen jeder versuch den
tritt zu finden endet in der verwirrung
auf einen krieg geführt
muss man den gegner verstehen können da
müssen vorankommen nicht und in dem sinn
habe ich das betrachten von anfang an
und habe mir gesagt ich bin nicht der
gefangenen der krankheit aber ich bin
auch nicht der buchhalter krankheit
sondern ich muss mich muss mich
verständigen
ich muss sehen was die macht bringt ihre
macht besteht
und wohin mein widerstand durchgehen
könnte also wenn ich nicht zum ziel
komme und oder zum telefon
da wenig in panik war diesmal bin ich
nicht
sich arrangieren damit dass die
krankheit alles beherrscht und ein leben
wie früher nicht mehr möglich ist
auch über die liebe schreibt richard
wagner und wie sie ihm abhanden kam
dann werden vorformen verändern den
menschen und sie verändern auch
psychisch nicht flüssig aber das alles
spielt eine rolle ich meine wenn man
zusammen ist mit dem man eine beziehung
die mädels ja nicht auf irgendeinen
detail ein bisschen wehmut auf dem
ganzen und das wollen die wenigsten
menschen so sehen und es spielt es auch
eine rolle wie der mensch aussieht was
er was er so wie er sich verhält nicht
eingang einen kranken menschen gerade
ein praktikum kranker mensch hat kann
dies nicht leisten so viel geduld zu
haben nicht ständig von den dämonen
geplatzt
ich möchte dass das ist ja nicht
überleben mit herrn parkinson richard
wagner versucht es mit großer
sprachgewalt mit zorn und trauer aber
auch humor taugliche rezepte gibt es
nicht